10 destremau ancien ambassadeur de
france
bonjour didier destro merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation des liens
diplomatiques franco américain toucher
bientôt couler ou bien une sortie de
crise sera trouvée la semaine prochaine
lors de l'assemblée générale de l'onu et
si oui laquelle
il est certain que c'est une sérieuse
désillusion une déception un attrait
important c'est aussi un rap et la dure
réalité la france en tant que france en
tant que membre de l'union européenne de
tests peu lourd même si dans le
pacifique est là elle a quand même une
implantation très importante avec la
nouvelle calédonie et surtout la
polynésie française donc ça c'est un
rappel pour de dire que nous français
nous ni européenne militairement
diplomatiquement
économiquement nous nous ne pesons pas
grand chose ceci étant je m'étonne quand
même de ce que la france n'ait pas été
alertée par sa
fille je pense que nos services de
renseignement devait avoir la puce à
l'oreille il va avoir entonné ce genre
de choses et bien évidemment informé
paris peut-être n'at-on pas été informée
ça c'est une discourtoisie total je
pense aussi qu'il faut maintenant se
placer si c'est possible du côté des
australiens
l'australien sait très bien que dans le
pacifique la france a des capacités et
une influence stratégique bien
inférieure à celle des états unis donc
il est normal de la part des australiens
d'avoir pris cette décision difficile
peut-être parce qu'ils aiment bien la
france globalement mais stratégiquement
important pour eux de se mettre de se
ranger sur la bannière américain est de
faire une espèce de grande alliance
stratégique
militaro politiques avec les états unis
est malheureusement la grande bretagne
qui nous faut de plus nos terreurs des
ddd flèche dans dans le dos comme a dit
jean yves le drian un coup dans le dos
c'est ce qu'il a dit le chef de la
diplomatie française mais vous n'avez
pas vraiment répondu à ma question pour
savoir comment est-ce que les relations
franco américaines peuvent s'améliorer
peut-être la semaine prochaine avec
l'assemblée générale de l'onu comme l'a
dit washington cette nuit
ne crois pas que ce buzz général de
l'onu soit une vérité un véritable
moment de réconciliation mais je pense
que globalement et à plus long terme on
reprendra des relations tout à fait
normal
les relations avec les états unis sont
importants pour nous que pour l'union
européenne et donc tout intérêt à se
rapprocher d'eux ceci étant il faut
quand même avaler la couleuvre et le
contrat ne sera pas
rétabli en aucun cas des ça restera
aussi dans nos dans notre conscience
dans notre souvenir que les américains
peuvent se comporter comme ça quand
leurs intérêts stratégiques domine est
que ces america first qui comptera
encore et toujours même pour nous
français qu'ils aient mon vous avez dit
le contrat ne sera pas rétabli jean yves
le drian a demandé cette semaine avoir
des explications et peut-être des
compensations mais à part annulé la
soirée de gala il ya à l'ambassade de
france à washington qu est ce que peut
faire pareil concrètement quelle marge
de manoeuvre
j'ignore les termes du contrat donc
juste sur cette affaire là je veux pas
me me définir il est clair que le que la
france peut engager en fonction de ce
qui est écrit qu'en contrat signé entre
l'australie et nous année une espèce de
deux démarches
notariale
d'avec un avocat mais j'ai pas
l'impression qu'on aura beaucoup de
compensation là-dessus
7/2 7-6 là c'est l'intérêt de
l'australie et des états unis de se
présenter contre la chine cette
rencontre aussi de l'opposition et je
crois qu'on n'aura absolument pas même
pas un cacahuètes comme compensation
pour ce contrat
la france est membre permanente du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu la france
est une puissance nucléaire mais ce que
c'est suffisant pour éviter d'être
marginalisée par d'autres puissances
on restera une puissance du clairet
nucléaire on restera membre de concept
de vérité on pèsera ce affaires du monde
des certainement en afrique et peut-être
au moyen-orient met dans pacific ou
composera de moins en moins devant cette
alliance entre australie etats unis et
grande bretagne on est en l1 1-1
politique amabilités 1a stratégique de
pacifier l'est la france doit mettre un
jour ou l'autre que nous sommes
d une puissance moyenne et plus des
grandes puissances qui est à qui ont
existé surtout après après la guerre de
14 comment est-ce que vous expliquer le
fait que paris semble isolé dans ce
dossier puisque on n'a pas entendu à
bruxelles on n'a pas entendu berlin les
alliés traditionnels de paris
c'est encore une fois le fond dommage
parce que si la france est concernée
directement là dedans c'est que aussi de
l'union européenne qu'il est il sait
c'est le poids de l'union européenne
entend terry qui est en jeu là aussi
c'est une puissance comme la france ne
peut pas imposer ou du moins participer
à une série d'actions dans le pacifique
avec des applications et qu'elle a c'est
toute l'union européenne qui souffre la
france quand même une des deux
puissances principal de l'union
européenne donc c'est fort dommage
effectivement que ni l'allemagne ni
nelly bruxelles en tant que union
européenne nenê
répondu n'ait
réagi à cette affaire là qu'est qui est
grave qui est grave pour les relations
bilatérales en tout cas mais aussi pour
les relations entre l'union européenne
et des états unis vous avez dire la
france une des grandes puissances de
l'union européenne avec l'allemagne
avant il y avait la grande bretagne
également qui était l'une des grandes
puissances de deux lieux on sait que
cette nouvelle alliance anglo saxonne
dans l'inde au pacifique inclut aussi
londres conséquence du bras exit
pour pour moi la grande bretagne n'a
jamais été réellement de l'union
européenne la grande bretagne a toujours
usé et tenter de diviser pour régner et
en particulier vis-à-vis de nous
français on a quand même de grands
contentieux n'ont même pas jusqu'à
jeanne d'arc et parlons du canada par
l'ong l'inde et parlant de fachoda et
parlons de toutes les conséquences de
delà de la guerre de 14 et la répartie
sur des colonies allemandes e.on en
afrique je crois pas que vraiment la
grande bretagne et était membre loyal de
l'union européenne bien évidemment ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui avec la faire
des sous marins australiens
c'est une des conséquences du principe
il est clair que la grande bretagne ne
fait fait bloc n'a pas et ne cherchent
pas du tout avant à défendre les
intérêts de la france bien évidemment
n'est pas en tout cas pas l'union
européenne s'est tout de suite il y aura
d'autres à mon avis merci didier
destremau d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
ancien ambassadeur de france